I accidentally became a meme and this is
that story my name is Sylvia Bottini but
you might know me as the first word
problems me
before I became a meme I was a stage
actor and I was dating this photographer
who wanted me to be always camera ready
because he was taking picture for the
microstock market so I had to wear
always makeup no branded t-shirt light
colors the kind of outfit that it's good
for a micro stock pictures because it
was selling all of it I was doing many
jobs for him all for free then one day
he wanted to explore the market the
business in China to see if it was a
good move to live there and so we booked
the tickets to go to Shanghai it was
2008 and that's where the picture that
became a meme was taken
it was practically a business travel
where I was translating modeling and
being a tourist during that travel we
happened to go to this really nice
Temple
he asked me to play different characters
different moods so I was meditating I
was looking around taking pictures and
then he asked me to cry
[Music]
the picture was on a stock image site
for a few years
and then on 2011 it became a meme
I had no clue what was a mean I figured
it out because a friend of mine who's
actually a webmaster texted me he sent
me the picture and it was like what is
that with the microstock you always sign
a liability form but in this case I I've
never signed for anything like that and
he was so excited he was like you have
no idea this is fantastic you're a mean
today I couldn't understand what was
this excitement about I thought this is
just an accident I don't want to be a
meme so it's gonna end soon I'm sure
well I didn't go
that way
[Music]
I wasn't really happy because these
exposures was about a picture where I
wasn't even recognizable on the other
hand I was kind of happy not to be
recognized because I didn't like the
character that I've been given these
really superficial person was always uh
crying about stupid stuff I'm not that
kind of person I'd rather have been a
crazy cat woman or the other meme the
one who who's smiling at her houses on
fire also didn't like the fact that
everybody could literally write whatever
they wanted on my face anytime with no
problem at all I I've read bad bad dirty
sentences really disrespectful I mean it
hurt I felt abused that's my face I've
even been accused of being an ungrateful
[ __ ] sorry for the French because
somebody was commenting that I should
have been so happy and grateful for
becoming a need at that point I was
really mad I was like come on dude
imagine yourself living your own life
and all of a sudden have somebody who
has the right to do whatever they want
with your face you can become whatever
character you have no power over that I
didn't get any money I was working
mostly for free I even discovered one
day somebody asked me why don't you sell
us the rights of the picture and I was
like well why not I mean some people
made a lot of money out of it so I wrote
to this ex-boyfriend and I told him look
they want to buy the the rights of the
picture that would be awesome what do
you think
[Music]
it went like oh I already did
it was like what you did and you didn't
even send me a card
thanking me for having been working for
free for years
I was in shock
so I I get it people like the meme and
I'm really really grateful for that I
really like to uh to make people laugh
we need definitely much more smiles and
laughing in this world but still I mean
I I I would like to be in charge of my
face to get my power back and this is
the reason why we thought with a couple
of friends we wanted to make the web
series I wanted to be
um interactive with the audience I
wanted to have all of the other meme
folk in it so they wrote a script a
really funny one we shot a teaser
you don't recognize me how about now
[Music]
and we started the crowdfunding but
we're not really tech savvy we didn't
know how to do that so it didn't work
out it's still a dream if you're
interested in something like that if you
would like to help visit my website and
feel free to reach out
foreign
[Music]